in the first video on devolution I gave
the example of the peppered moth during
the industrial revolution in England and
how before the Industrial Revolution
there was a bunch of moths some were
dark somewhere light somewhere in
between but then once everything became
soot filled all of a sudden the dark
moths were less likely to be caught by
predators and so all of the white moths
got were less likely to be able to
reproduce successfully so the black moth
trait or that variant dominated and then
if you came a little bit later and you
saw the black moor all the moths have
turned black it's like oh these moths
are geniuses they appear to have somehow
engineered their way to stay camouflaged
and and and the point I was making there
is that look that wasn't engineered or
an explicit move but on the part of the
moths or the DNA that that was just a
natural byproduct of them having some
variation and some of that variation was
selected for so with that example that
was pretty simple black or white but
what about more complicated things so
for example here here I have a couple of
pictures what's commonly called the owl
butterfly and what's amazing here and
it's pretty obvious if I probably don't
have to point out to you is it it looks
like it's it's it's its wing looks like
half of an owl's eye I mean I can almost
you know draw a beak here you know and
draw another wing there and you can
imagine an owl staring at us right and
here too I could imagine a beak here and
you would think an owl on there too and
so the question is how does something
this good show up randomly right I mean
you could imagine okay little spots or
black and white or gray but how does
something that looks so much like an i
generate randomly now the answer is well
there's a couple of answers one is why
does this exist or this this I like
pattern or this owl like eyes pattern
and they're the the jury's still out on
that idler I read a little bit of it
about it on Wikipedia and these are all
of these images I got from Wikipedia and
Wikipedia they said look there's two
there's two competing theories here one
theory is that this you know in the this
is even though to us humans the way we
see things it looks like an owl's eye
that this is actually a decoy that this
is you know when some predator is about
to chase is about to chase
these these wants to eat one of these
things they kind of go for the thing
that looks most substantive so instead
of going for the the butterfly's body
which is you know it doesn't look that
substantive they go for the big black
thing they say oh that looks like it's
protein rich and it'll be a good meal so
they try to snap and bite at that and if
they bite at that sure the guy's wings
are going to be clipped a little bit and
it's going to suck but the but the
animal itself the the the actual
butterfly would survive and maybe you
know it can it can repair its wings I
don't know the actual biology of the owl
butterfly that's one theory and then the
argument against that goes well know if
that was the case and you would want the
black spot even further back along its
you know you'd want the spot way far
away from the body you'd want it back
here instead of right here because
there's still a chance if something
chomps it this little black spot that
it'll still get the abdomen of the
butterfly now the most the other theory
as to why this exists and you know who
knows maybe it's a little bit of both
maybe both of these are true maybe this
offers two advantages the other theory
and this is kind of the one that jumps
out at us when we see this hey this
looks like an owl maybe this is to scare
away the things that would are likely to
eat this dude so maybe if and it does
turns out in my reading that it
they are lizards that like to eat these
type of butterflies and those lizards
probably don't like to be around Birds
or owls because those owls eat them so
that might be deterrent and then the
other example they said is look they
tend to be eaten by this lizard right
here this is what Wikipedia told me and
that this lizard tends to be eaten by
this frog right there and that the eyes
of this butterfly are not too dissimilar
to the eyes of this frog and you know we
can debate whether or not that's the
case and if if this was the predator
we're trying to mimic you could make an
argument that maybe we would have had
more green on our wing but that's not
the point of this video and but it's a
fun discussion to have as to what is
useful about the side but let's have the
question why how did that eye come about
I want to say that I I mean the pattern
on that wing what what set of events
allow this to happen because when I
described evolution and we know that
everything in our biological Kingdom is
just a set of proteins and then stuff
that may be the protein cap but mainly
protein and that proteins all coded for
by DNA
I'm going to do future videos on DNA but
DNA is just a sequence of base pairs
it's a sequence of these molecules and
we represent the you know adenine and
guanine and then cytosine and thymine
and remember you have a couple of
adenine x' in a row and some guanine and
thymine and I'll do a lot more on this
in the future but the idea is it's look
it's just coded for by this sequence of
these molecules how do you get a
sequence you know how do you go from a
butterfly that has no eye to all of a
sudden I that goes there obviously just
one change that happens from a random
mutation may be that G turns into an A
or that or maybe this C and this T get
deleted so everything that alone isn't
going to develop this beautiful of a
pattern or this this useful of a pattern
so how does how do the random changes
explain something that that's this
intricate and this is my explanation and
obviously you know I wasn't sitting
there watching over the thousands or
millions of years as these owl
butterflies emerge so this is just my
theory of how natural selection does
explain this type of phenomenon you have
a world where you have in some
environment you have butterflies and
their wings look like you know let's say
you have some butterflies that are
generally like this that's their wing
and it's a very bad drawing but I think
you get the idea and there's just some
general patterns we've seen it before
there's variation and the variation does
show up from these little random changes
in DNA I think we can all believe that
that most of these changes are kind of
benign maybe they just set up
differently where a little pattern will
show up or a little speck of of pigment
will show up with a slightly different
color and we even see amongst these owl
butterflies there is variation this
dude's wing is different than that guy's
wing what the commonality that they do
have these eye looking shapes and
there's not just one there's actually
multiple this guy has this other thing
up here that looks interesting and they
have multiple things but the one really
noticeable feature is this eye looking
thing so how do we go from this to an
eye looking thing so the idea is you
have some variation one guy might look
like that another guy or gal my register
and 'm there dot might might be
something like that another gal or guy
these wings are really badly drawn
but you get the idea that this is the
butterfly says antenna right there
that's its body another another person's
patterns might or butterfly's patterns
might look like this right and so
they're just random but when they go
into a certain environment for whatever
reason maybe one of its predators maybe
that theory that these are supposed to
look like eyes is true
and so actually maybe maybe this guy
just has a random pattern here so maybe
for this and so this guy and I'm not
saying that one it's like definitely
better that they're both going to be
found and killed by predators but just
it's all probabilistic right maybe this
guy has a 1% chance less chance of
getting a predator because when you
predator just looks at them out of the
corner of that eye that little really
hazy region kind of looks like an eye
and a predator would be better off just
not messing with it and they'd rather go
after the dude that looks like this so
it's just a slight probability now you
might say ok what's 1% going to do but
when you compound that 1% over thousands
and thousands of generations all of a
sudden this trait might dominate and
because he's just going to be killed
that less frequently 1% less frequently
now maybe this guy has a similar trait
but his spot is closer to the abdomen
and here it's a trade-off because maybe
some predators get scared away by this
concentration of pigment and once again
this is not I'm not saying that we're
here yet we're not at this kind of very
advanced sophisticated pattern yet where
this just this random concentration of
pigment that just shows up so we see
that people who have this concentration
of pigment further away from their
abdomen they do well but when it's too
close maybe some predators think that
that's actually an insect and they want
to eat it so that's actually a bad
that's actually a bad trait so what
happens is this guy dominates and so
within this population you start having
a lot of variation because he starts
representing them this he's more likely
to pass on these traits and I want to
make that clear that point very clear
this isn't what happens over the course
of an animal's lifetime it's not like if
somehow I experience something or at
least our current theory if I experience
something that I can somehow pass on
that knowledge to my child what it says
is if I experience some if my DNA just
happens to
just some variation that happens to be
more useful or more likely for me to
survive to reproduction and for my
children to survive then that will start
to dominate in the population so then
the population you're going to have
variations within that maybe some guys
you know it's going to get a little bit
look like that
maybe another one's going to look a
little bit like that maybe some spots
there you can kind of view it as the
variation is quote-unquote exploring but
I want to be very clear not to use any
active verbs here because this is all
being done really as a as a almost a
common-sense process where everything
changes the changes that are most suited
are the ones that are going to survive
more frequently and then the next
generation is going to have more of that
and then you'll you'll have variation
within that change and then this one
might be like that and maybe this is the
one you know these were you good
compared to that but now when you're
competing amongst themselves
this one is able to reproduce 1% more
then this guy or this guy and then you
can so this guy becomes and maybe it's
some combination of all the well and
they mix and match it's a hugely complex
system but then this guy represents most
of the population and when I say this
guy I'm saying this guy's genetic
information at least as which pertains
to his wings and then you get variation
amongst that maybe some of it they have
a little small dot and there's some dots
around it maybe it's like this may be
one of them digresses and goes back here
but then he has trouble competing so he
gets knocked out again and then some
other people haven't that back here I
think you get the point that this isn't
happening overnight it's hope it
happening just these changes can be
fairly incremental but we're doing it
over thousands of generations so when
you're talking about thousands of
generations or even millions of
generations even a 1% advantage can be
significant and when you accumulate
those variations over a large period of
time you can get to fairly intricate
patterns like this so I just wanted to
explain that because that you know this
is often used as a you know how does
sure I can believe the butterfly moth or
I could even maybe believe the examples
of the antibiotics and the bacteria or
the flu and because those are kind of
real-time examples but how does
something this intricate show up and
actually want to make a point here we
think this is more intricate
because we can relate to it in our
everyday lives but if you actually look
at the structure of a bacteria and how
it operates or what a virus does to
infiltrate an immune system or a cell
that's actually on a lot more levels a
lot more intricate than a design in fact
the whole reason why I'm using this as
an example is because this is a fairly
simple example as opposed to kind of
explaining the metabolism of a certain
type of bacteria and how that might
change and how it might become immune to
penicillin or whatever else but I want
to make this very clear that these very
intricate things they don't happen
overnight it's not like one butterfly
was you know all of us was you know
completely looked like one uniform hot
pink color and then all of a sudden they
have a child who whose wings looked just
like this no it happens over large
periods of time although there might be
some little weird hormonal change that
does this but I'm not going to go go
there but that is possible but I just
want to make this point because I think
the more examples we see the more it'll
kind of hit home that this is a passive
process we're not talking about these
things happening overnight and it's
actually really it's really interesting
to kind of look at our world around us
and look at ecosystems as they are today
and try to think really hard about how
something came to be what it's useful
for why it might have been selected for
for example I'll leave you know our
things are traits that occur after
reproduction selected for well probably
not unless they affect the reproduction
of the next cycle for example it is you
might say oh well the trait to be
nurturing after your reproductive a
years that say you know that's after
reproductive years nobody it helps your
your offspring reproduce but you know we
already see a lot of diseases especially
once we get beyond our reproductive and
our child-rearing years so once we get
into our 50s and 60s the incidences of
diseases it increases exponentially from
when we were younger and that's because
they're no longer being selected for
because it no longer affects our ability
to reproduce because we've already
reproduced we've already raised our
children so that they could reproduce so
anything that happens that point is now
not being selected for so anyway
hopefully this video gave you a little
bit more nuance on evolution and I want
to do a couple of videos like this
because I really want to make it clear
that it's not making some wild
you know claim that all of a sudden this
appear spontaneously that it really is a
thing that happens over millennia and
eons and very gradually